while the rain passed through las vegas
rather quickly other parts of
southern nevada really got hit hard
places like perum facing some dangerous
driving conditions
these are telephone poles floating down
the road
come on come on buddy
unfortunately those flooded roadways
were just some of the ways the storms
have impacted that community madison
kimbrough continues
our team coverage from pahrump where
some say they haven't seen a downpour
like this in years
damage in trump is extensive from heavy
flooding to uprooted trees like the one
that you see right here
in this neighborhood
[Applause]
it woke me up about 10 30 the thunder
lightning flashing all around
tom wilcox recalls the intense storm
from sunday into monday afternoon he
says the rainfall was so loud he was
worried his windows would shatter
and as for the flooding this is video he
took of his street
he says he didn't dare leave the house
but saw some cars trying to make it
through
it was up about this far in our driveway
it's probably a foot deep in the road
yeah just flowing over at the pahrump
valley speedway owner chad
broadhead said it's been years since
he's seen this amount of flooding
and unfortunately the damage will cost
him and we just put a whole new surface
on this racetrack just a month ago
which cost a few thousand dollars to do
and now it's all washed out so we've got
to redo it
and as you can see behind me you can see
anywhere from six to 12 feet of water
in both our lower pit parking and our
racetrack so what's next for the
speedway
broadhead says at this point it's a
waiting game we cancel our races for a
while
we start back in and do a complete
cleanup
we try to fix our buildings as for the
damage you can see the cleanup has begun
and the owner of this home says it could
have been much worse he's just happy
that his roof is still intact
reporting in pahrump madison kimbrough 8
news now